we're now going to tackle Part B of the
potato problem and it says use the
second derivative of H with respect to
time to determine whether your answer in
Part A is an underestimate or an
overestimate of the internal temperature
of the potato at time T is equal to 3 so
in Part A we found the equation of the
tangent line at time equals 0 and we use
that to estimate what our internal
temperature would be at time is equal to
3 so how is the second derivative going
to help us think whether that was an
overestimate or an underestimate well
the second derivative can help us know
about concavity and let us know well is
our slope increasing over this interval
or is our slope decreasing and then we
can use that to estimate whether we
overestimated or not so first let's just
find the second derivative so we have
the first derivative written up here let
me just rewrite it and I'll distribute
the negative 1/4 because it'll be a
little bit more straightforward then so
if I write the derivative of H with
respect to time is equal to negative 1/4
times our internal temperature which
itself is a function of time and then
negative 1/4 times negative 27 that
would be plus 27 over 4 let me scroll
down a little bit
so now let me leave that graph up there
because I think that might be useful
what is the second derivative going to
be with respect to time so I'll write it
right over here D the second derivative
of H with respect to time is going to be
equal to well the derivative of this
first term with respect to time it's
going to be the derivative of this with
respect to H times the derivative of H
with respect to time so this is equal to
negative 1/4 that's the derivative of
this term with respect to H and then we
want to multiply that times the
derivative of H with respect to time
this comes just straight out of the
chain rule and then the derivative of a
constant how does that change with
respect to time it's not going to change
that is just going to be 0 so just like
that we were able to find the second
derivative H with respect to time and
now what does this tell us
what
well we talked about in the previous
video that over the interval that we
care about
Falacci I can show you from this graph
over the interval that we care about for
T greater than zero it says that our
internal temperature is always going to
be greater than twenty seven and so when
you look at this expression here or when
you look at this expression here for
dhdt
we talked to the previous video how this
is always going to be negative here
because H is always going to be greater
than twenty seven so that part's going
to be positive but then we're going to
multiply it by a negative 1/4 so our
slope dhdt our derivative of our
temperature with respect to time is
always going to be negative
so we could write that this or this this
is going to be negative let me write it
this way since H is greater than 27 for
T is greater than 0 we know that DHD T
is negative is negative so we could say
that this right over here since d h dt
is less than 0 for t is greater than 0
the second derivative of H with respect
to T is going to be greater than 0 for T
is greater than 0 and so what does that
mean it means that we are if your second
derivative is positive that means you're
concave upward concave upward which
means slope is increasing slope
increasing or you could say slope less
becoming less negative slope becoming
less negative now what does that mean
and you can see it intuitively if the
slope is becoming less and less negative
then that means when we approximated
what our temperature is at T equals 3 we
used a really negative slope when in
reality our slope is getting less and
less and less negative so what we would
have done is we would have over
decreased our temperature from T equals
0 to T equals 3 so that would mean that
we would have underestimated it so let
me write that down and I'm running out
of a little bit of space but let me
write it right over here so that implies
so this implies that underestimate under
estimate in Part A and if I were taking
this on the AP exam I would flesh out to
my language a little bit here to make it
a little clearer but hopefully that
makes sense